Bible in a year remains one of the top  podcasts in the country Bible in a year  right now is the number three podcast in  the country according to the charts do  you know what the number two podcast is  the Bible recap which is another Bible  podcast this one put out by D group do  you know what the number one podcast in  the country is catechism in a year also  with father Mike Schmitz who does Bible  linear this one Catholic priest is the  host of two of the three most popular  podcasts in the country  one of which is on the Bible one of  which is on the catechism of the  Catholic Church and then the podcast  that's wedged right in the middle of  those two is the top three  is also a Bible podcast this is great  news but it tells me that there is a  longing in the country  to return to that which is true and good  and beautiful